Chris, can you tell me about a challenge or a conflict that you've faced in the workplace...
...and how you would deal with it?
Sure. Prior to teaching, I was involved with a photography company,...
...photographing events like weddings and bar mitzvahs...
...and very, very important events in people's lives.
And a lot of times, conflicts would arise.
So, again, just like in teaching, overcoming those conflicts with patience...
...and listening to the client or customers' needs is very important.
Now, you are interviewing for a position that is not an entry-level position...
...and there is the possibility that those in our company...
...that were overlooked for this position may have some animosity...
...regarding the new hire for this position.
So, how do you approach this potential challenge here at the workplace?
The important thing is to listen to the people around me...
...and understand that I am a newcomer...
...and that they know more about the work environment than I will coming in.
We here at REI, you know, it is being in customer service,...
...there are aspects of your job that are going to be a little less active...
...than I could expect you being in a teaching position...
...where I assume you're on your feet, more one-on-one, face-to-face with individuals.
Do you prefer a specific type of work environment?
Do you thrive in a variety of work environments and what does this look like?
Well, I thrive in a variety of work environments.
I wouldn't expect to be sitting in a cubicle, interacting with customers,...
...unless I'm handling a phone call and that's fine, that's part of the job.